president Trump raises the prospect of
civil war the questions of slavery and
states rights caused the first Civil War
will Joe Biden's sons degenerate
business dealings in Ukraine caused a
second one we will examine the
likelihood of Civil War two
electric boogaloo then a puberty
blocking drug used in transgender
treatment has killed 6,000 children
nothing to see here folks and new york
city outlaws the phrase illegal alien
they don't outlaw illegal aliens they
welcome illegal aliens they just outlaw
clear language we'll get to all that and
more I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
here comes the Civil War proving Karl
Marx's adage that history repeats itself
first is tragedy then as farce we will
get into all the forest achill aspects
of it from Rudy Giuliani as excellent
performance on George Stephanopoulos
show to the Ukraine to the White House
to Joe Biden to everything in between
but first I've got to thank our friends
over at Mint Mobil oh how I love mint
mobile mint mobile I put it very bluntly
they can cut your cell phone bill down
to 15 bucks a month for the same premium
coverage that's it that's pretty much
all I should need to say but I know what
you're thinking you're thinking what I
thought when I heard about min Mobile
which is this is too good to be true
there's something here it's not real
it's there's gonna be all these hidden
fees no mint Mobile knows what they're
doing
your old wireless bill pays for
expensive retail stores they pay for
overhead and they charge you they up
charge you for unlimited data that
you're never ever going to use think of
all the times that you're on Wi-Fi all
day you're on Wi-Fi at home you're on
Wi-Fi at the office you're on Wi-Fi and
a lot of other places too so you're just
not using that data and that is what
they're up charging you for mint mobile
reimagined how to buy Wireless made it
all online pass the savings on directly
to you you can cut your wireless bill
down to 15 bucks a month every plan
comes with unlimited nationwide talking
text plus it insanely fast 4G LTE data
that's everything that's all you need
it's not like you're only gonna get two
minutes of talk per month unlimited talk
unlimited text crazy fast 4G LTE data
you use your own phone with any mint
mobile plan you keep your same phone
number
with all of your existing contacts if
you are not 100% satisfied don't worry
about it it's not like you had to get
locked into some lifetime eternity plan
mint mobile has you covered with their
seven day money-back guarantee but you
are gonna love it it is incredible get
your new Wireless plan for just fifteen
bucks a month think about how much
you're paying right now I can't even
imagine when I think about my old cell
phone bills it makes me very angry
because it was like setting money on
fire get your plan down to 15 bucks a
month right now get the plan shipped to
your door for free go to mint mobile
comm slash anoles
Cana wles that is mi n
mint mobile mo b IL e comm slash knowles
cut your bill down to 15 bucks a month
mint mobile comm slash knowles
all right now on to less important
matters than saving money on your cell
phone plan the Civil War Civil War is
coming isn't it why are we talking about
the Civil War but the proximate cause is
President Trump on Twitter it's always
on Twitter quoted a Southern Baptist
pastor named Robert Jeffress who said
quote if the Democrats this is quoting
both the pastor and president Trump's
tweet if the Democrats are successful in
removing the president from office which
they will never be it will cause a civil
war like fracture in this nation from
which our country will never heal a
civil war like fracture Trump didn't put
the hyphen in there okay that's fine
pastor Robert Jeffress said it on Fox
News the left lost their mind over this
tweet they lose I don't know how do you
lose your mind if you don't have your
mind any more they've lost their mind a
thousand times it's not their mind
anymore and they don't have it but they
they really got upset about this
president Trump didn't say were headed
for civil war Robert Jeffress didn't say
that we're headed towards civil war I'm
beginning to wonder if leftists in this
country are not just misguided but
illiterate too in fact I know they're
illiterate the way that they pervert
language the way that they call men
women and women men and say that some
people don't have any gender and use the
vay which is the plural pronoun to refer
to singular people and now in New York
City you can't even say the phrase
illegal alien with that incurring a
criminal fine so yeah I guess they are
illiterate never mind let's look at what
they actually said Jeffress and Trump in
the tweet they say it will cause a civil
war like fracture in this nation on and
on but the premise is if the Democrats
are successful in removing the president
from office
they're not going to be I'm not saying
this is wishful thinking I'm saying this
because even if they impeach Trump which
they currently don't really have the
votes for in the house even if they did
they don't have the Senate so it's
they're probably not even going to take
it up for a vote on whether or not to
convict Trump if the house had beaches
even if they did take it up for a vote
even if there was now
one Republican in the Senate even if the
Senate was all Democrats according to a
morning consult Bowl from last week not
even two thirds of Democrats in this
country support impeachment they're
pretty close it's about 66 percent you
would need 67% to convict the President
and remove him from office so even if
you got rid of every republican in the
country and specifically every
republican in the senate they still
wouldn't remove trump from office not
going to happen which is why Jeffress
and then from quoting him said even if
the democrats are successful parentheses
which they will never be nevertheless
democrats very upset about this and both
the pastor and trump bring up a question
worth talking about Karl Marx observed
that history repeats itself first is
tragedy then as farce Karl Marx was
wrong about many things but it seems he
was right about that there are some
parallels between the Civil War and what
we're looking at now what what are those
parallels what caused the Civil War the
actual first Civil War in 1860 most
importantly was the moral question of
slavery Americans were divided over the
question of slavery this was a profound
moral question the founders of this
country were debating it in the late
19th century when we wrote the
Declaration of Independence the first
draft one of the grievances that we were
complaining about to King George was
about this awful institution of slavery
that the English foisted upon the
incipient United States the growing
United States so the question of slavery
was there from the very beginning of the
country and then that was largely the
cause of the war after that was the
constitutional question about the
relative roles of the federal government
in the states can the states secede if
they want to are they are they allowed
to leave you know they stay in the Union
when it's beneficial to them once they
think it's not beneficial anymore are
they permitted to secede I mean
practically speaking the proximate cause
of the Civil War was the election of
1860 the presidential election and the
refusal of the south to recognize
Abraham Lincoln as president
or I suppose they did recognize him as
president they said we don't want any
part of this and they got out of the
union what happened what happened in
1862 cause the Civil War Abraham Lincoln
won just 40 percent of the popular vote
he won more than the other candidates
but he didn't win the majority of the
popular vote in the United States he
didn't win more than 50 percent Lincoln
hadn't even been on the ballot in most
of the southern states he wasn't there
of the 11 states that seceded upon his
election only Virginia had any votes
cast for Lincoln at all and you know
many votes were cast for Lincoln in
Virginia in 1860 a little under two
thousand votes 1929 votes which is 1.15
percent of the total number of votes
cast gets even worse than that of those
1929 votes 1832 of the votes came from
territories that would become West
Virginia so they were politically not
even really associated or recognizable
with Virginia as a whole why were there
so few votes cast forget about the other
states where Lincoln wasn't on the
ballot or that weren't ballots to vote
for him because of presidential election
voting in 1860 looked significantly
different than it does today
one of the reasons that there were so
few votes cast for Lincoln is there was
no secret ballot in the United States we
didn't really have a secret ballot
before the 1880s 20 years later 25 years
later so there was one reason why you
saw a little more homogeneity with the
votes is you had a public ballot so if
you cast your vote for Lincoln you would
certainly be socially ostracized if not
worse so you actually can understand the
argument of the south to secede if you
put slavery aside don't even consider
that for a second just look at the
practical matter with regard to the
federal government and the local
governments the South felt that they had
no say in their federal government so
what's the point of being involved in it
if you're part of an organization that
you don't think is serving you in any
way why would you why would you be a
member of that so the cause of civil war
this is the big point and this is where
the relationship comes up today the
cause of the Civil War is generally
speaking an erosion of faith in
institutions and systems of government
this is true by definition which is that
once you once you pull out of those
institutions once you clobber those
institutions once you storm them and
take them down
obviously you don't have faith in them
anymore we are looking at a similar
crisis today and on the surface it's the
for sickle version so in 2018 or in I'm
sorry in 1860 the great debate is over
human dignity it's over freedom it's
over slavery it's over man being made in
the image of God now in 2019 the great
debate is how much Joe Biden helped get
his crackhead son and no-show job in
Ukraine these are not exactly the the
same wait wait eNOS to those questions
but there is an institutional question
we'll get to that in a second we'll get
to the prospect of Civil War first I've
got to thank our friends over at Ashford
University I'm so glad to welcome this
new sponsor Ashford University is
providing huge opportunities for people
and a huge opportunity to take a step
forward in your career with an MBA
without having to totally stop your life
put your life on hold while you do it if
you've been feeling stuck I know a lot
of people who feel this way you feel
stuck you feel like you've hit a glass
ceiling you feel like you just can't go
any further in your career earning an
MBA could be the thing to help get you
moving forward and I'm here to tell you
that earning your MBA is easier than
ever thanks to Ashford University you
know we have talked a lot on this show
about how the educational establishment
has been rotted out hollowed out from
within and there it is causing to too
much trouble for people it's not
offering the same value it's not
offering to give you the personalized
kind of education you need for over a
century for over a century
consider this Forbes has been one of the
top names in business by partnering with
Ashford University they have built an
incredible online MBA degree program
that helps prepare students to become
leaders in business this is the Forbes
School of Business and Technology it is
led by a faculty of practicing business
professionals who bring their years of
experience to the classroom with Ashford
University courses you'll learn by doing
their courses led by industry experts
they use interactive business
simulations and innovative strategies
such as
gamification which I love in education I
use a lot of my own and to enhance your
learning experience Ashford University's
online MBA allows you to learn at your
own pace six-week courses allow you to
take one course at a time this is fully
accredited by the W ASC senior college
and university commission you just if
you want to make a change if you want to
pursue your your ambitions if you want
to pursue not only your passions but
your career build your life do it on
your terms Ashford University can be a
great way to do it you can achieve your
master's degree while balancing work and
home life start earning your masters
today enroll now by going to Ashford dot
edu slash Knowles KO wles
Ashford dot edu slash and olds Kano wles
to start your master's degree today
Ashford edu / Knowles really terrific
opportunity okay so in 1860 you've got
this debate over human dignity and and
the nature of man in 2019 you've got
this question over whether Joe Biden's
degenerate son who squandered his
family's money on prostitutes and drugs
and got mugged while he was buying crack
in downtown LA whether he should be able
to keep his grifter boardmember job on a
Ukrainian energy company not exactly the
same thing but the institutional
question is has the bureaucracy becomes
so entrenched that they can overturn a
u.s. presidential election has the
federal government taken so much power
that it doesn't matter who you and I
elect president doesn't matter who the
people want to be president doesn't
matter who the people through our
constitutional systems want to elect the
bureaucracy is going to tell you yes or
no because there is a real parallel
there in 1860 the South felt that they
had no say in their federal government
anymore if the American people are going
to be disfranchised by a growing
bureaucracy our Benevolent betters who
know how to run our lives better than we
know how to run them ourselves just ask
them then you are going to see some
civil strife what did we learn we have
just learned that between last May May
of 2018 and August of 2019 keep that
last date in mind the intelligence
community
secretly got rid of a requirement that
whistleblowers provide direct first-hand
knowledge of alleged wrongdoings why
does this matter
because this whole impeachment inquiry
was spurred by a whistleblower complaint
but what's so strange about that
whistleblower complaint and we'll get
into that in a second is the
whistleblower doesn't know anything
about what President Trump did or didn't
do in Ukraine said or didn't say to the
Ukrainian president on the telephone he
just heard about it from a few people
and then he sent it over and there was
an investigation and Trump was cleared
of violations from the DOJ but it was
all based on hearsay it was all second
or third-hand now under the old rules
you weren't allowed to file a complaint
just based on hearsay so what changed
will coincidentally shortly before this
whistleblower filed his complaint the
intelligence community changed the rules
and that's what a coincidence what are
the odds that the intelligence community
would do that at the very time you know
the intelligence community which tried
to overturn the 2016 election which was
against Trump from the very beginning
I'm not I don't want to I don't want to
disparage the hole I see there's some
great people in the intelligence
community but there's some really bad
actors out there who were really upset
that Trump got elected and they decided
to grossly abuse their power and try to
overturn the decision of the people
Lindsey Graham Senator Lindsey Graham
Lindsey Graham both we call him Graham
2.0 ever since he became this real bold
face of conservatism he brought this
question up on Face the Nation and he
made the the only conclusion you can
draw which is something about this
whistleblower complaint stinks every
American deserves to confront their
accuser so this is a sham as far as I'm
concerned I want to know who told the
whistleblower about the phone call I
want to know why they changed the rules
about whistleblowers not the hearsay
rule was changed just a short period of
time for the complaint was filed the
complaint
sounds like a legal document who helped
him who helped this guy write it or this
girl write it we're not going to try the
president United States based on hearsay
every American has a right to confront
their accuser
of course every American has the right
to confront their accuser we're not
going to throw president out of office
because some random guy in the CIA or
any other intelligence agency decides
that he doesn't like Trump and he's
gonna write up this complaint there's a
lot that's weird about the complaint but
Lindsey Graham has been very good about
talking about this on TV about
distilling this down to its basics the
other one who's been really great is
Rudy Giuliani and I know that Rudy gets
a lot of flack because sometimes he
overstepped sorry misstates things or he
says things on TV that he shouldn't have
on this issue on Ukraine this is Rudy at
his best he is doing an excellent job
here he's doing an excellent job of
shutting down all of the objections from
the mainstream media because don't
forget the media are not a neutral body
when it comes to Ukraine the media have
been complicit in shutting down this
story about Joe Biden's corruption
they've been complicit since 2014 they
haven't talked about this
they've been complicit in pushing the
Russia hoax they've been complicit in
pushing this impeachment nonsense and so
Rudy Giuliani goes on George
Stephanopoulos show George
Stephanopoulos he's the head of polit
political news over there at ABC and
people forget because we have a short
political attention span George
Stephanopoulos was Bill Clinton's
communications director in the White
House on the campaign this guy was in
the war room he was Bill Clinton's hack
and hatchet man
and now that same guy is the head of
news for ABC political news for ABC Rudy
Giuliani goes on there and he makes the
first point that we should all ask
ourselves when whenever there's a
political scandal you should ask
yourself if it were the other side doing
this would it bother me as much what
would I say if the shoe were on the
other foot now that doesn't mean that
you have to treat both sides equally
both sides are not equal they're trying
to get different things that to teams
are playing for different goals but you
should at least ask yourself so that you
have some real political perspective and
some intellectual honesty that's what
really on ask George Stephanopoulos he
says if the shoe were on the other foot
here and we weren't talking about Joe
Biden and hunter Biden but Donald Trump
and Donald Trump jr. would you still say
there's nothing wrong there's nothing to
see here of course the answer is
absolutely not I also support everything
I say with affidavits
I have an affidavit here that's been
online for six months did nobody barter
the read from the gentleman who was
fired victor Shogun the so-called
corrupt prosecutor the Biden people say
that he wasn't investigating hunter
Biden at the time he says under oath
that he was but as you know I know he
says that I don't even know him we know
that Vice President Biden was part of an
international effort was part of a
government-wide effort to push the the
prosecutor up name as the name was the
Donald Trump and Donald Trump jr. and it
said that the President of the Ukraine
asked me to resign due to pressure from
the US presidential administration the
truth is that I was forced out because I
was leading a wide-ranging Perosh
corruption corruption probe into barrese
mo Holdings and Joe Biden's son there it
is and by the way importantly Rudy
Giuliani isn't just using hearsay
third-hand from some CIA hack who got
his pals in the intelligence community
to change the rules so he could put a
rumor out there to try to get Trump
impeached Rudy is holding a sworn
affidavit rudy is starting to deal in
real evidence real facts the real words
of the people who were involved here not
just the mainstream media gossip mill
and rumor mill and he's asking what if
the shoe were on the other foot it is
not just conservatives who are raising
this prospect no less a liberal than
Bill Maher Bill Maher hates Donald Trump
Bill Maher said he's hoping for a
recession just so that Trump doesn't get
reelected he's got real liberal bona
fides Bill Maher goes at says exactly
the same thing that if this were not Joe
Biden hunter Biden but Donald Trump and
Donald Trump jr. that is all the leftist
media it's all Rachel Maddow and
everybody else would be talking about
why I read about this no I don't think
he was doing something terrible in
Ukraine but it's just so why can't
politicians tell their kids get a job
get a god
this kid this kid who's paid $600,000
because his name is Biden by a gas
company in Ukraine this super corrupt
country that just had a revolution to
get rid of corruption it just looks bad
it does sound like something John jr.
would do and if John jr. did it it would
be all Rachel Maddow was talking about
yes I do like when Bill Maher does this
because Bill Maher still gets his snide
left-wing insinuations in there says
like Don jr. would totally do this I
don't see any reason to conclude that
Don jr. would do something like this
there is no comparison between Don Jr
who has made some missteps in life sure
so have we all and hunter Biden who got
discharged from the Navy after a month
for testing positive for Coke squandered
all his family's money on drugs and
hookers then I went to Skid Row in LA
and bought crack and had a gun pulled on
and then drunk drove to Arizona where he
would have been arrested for possession
of a crack pipe and drunk driving except
the cops declined to pursue charges and
then grifted 600k a year by trading on
his father's name in the Ukraine and got
a billion and a half dollars in loans
from the Chinese government also trading
on his father's name no comparison okay
but Bill Maher will get his snide
insinuations and then say if it were Don
jr. it's all Rachel Maddow would be
talking about and of course that's true
this is why I want to talk about this
shoe on the other foot calling balls and
strikes if Trump does it you got to call
him out the same way that you would call
that a Democrat I'm more than willing to
criticize things that President Trump
says and criticize things that President
Trump does I'm at the same time willing
to support him politically even while I
criticize him for those things why why
will some conservatives defend President
Trump when he does things that are
objectively objectionable they will
defend him in those cases if what he's
doing is contextually defensible though
it's slightly complicated terms and it's
a little bit of a nuanced point so what
do I mean President Trump goes and he
talks about civil war I think it's bad
to do that I don't like that he does
that I don't want other people to go out
there and talk about civil war I don't
want the certainly don't what the
president of United States to do that
what he is doing when he says that is
objectively objectionable however he
didn't start this fight
he's not the one pushing for civil war
he's not the one clamoring for it he's
not the first one suggesting it if he's
not the second one suggesting it and
he's not the 5,000th of person
suggesting him what Trump is doing when
he calls for Sarah when he suggests that
we could be on the verge of a civil war
is he's showing the double standard he's
showing the hypocrisy he's not just
talking about this double standard in
the hypocrisy he by making these
statements and showing us the reaction
that they get is actually showing the
hypocrisy of the left in the media and I
think that's a great thing and I hate it
when conservatives unilaterally disarm
David French over a National Review whom
I like I feel like I have to call him
David French whom I like
because sometimes I criticize what he
says particularly his opinions on Donald
Trump but he's a very nice guy so I
don't want it to be clear that I like
him personally but David French whom I
like called a president Trump for
exactly this reason he says it's awful
when Trump does this and we would call
him out if he were a Democrat and here's
what French said directly quote I know I
know but let's do this anyway if a
Democratic president had accused a GOP
committee chair of treason and
approvingly quoted a threat of a second
civil war from an unhinged religious
leader then I think we know exactly how
Republicans would respond okay that's
what he says see how you hypocrite
Republicans you hypocrite Trump's
supporters
the problem with David's point is we
don't need to imagine this we don't need
to imagine that the leaders of the
Democratic Party called for civil strife
and accused Donald Trump of treason
they've been doing it for three years
that's the whole point that's why Trump
did it that's the effect of Trump doing
it is you calling the hypocrisy and I
seeing the hypocrisy President Trump is
not going to util at orally disarm he's
not going to just go along and allow us
to be bullied by the left in this way
it happened you switch a couple rolls
obviously because Trump is the president
now but it did happen for three years
the left and the mainstream media have
called Trump a traitor explicitly
they're still doing it today just last
week bill weld who's a liberal
Republican running against Trump in the
2020 Republican primary called Trump a
traitor and said he should be publicly
executed when he did that he was cheered
on by portions of the mainstream media
and the left when the ones who didn't
want to cheer him on stayed silent they
were complicit and the Democratic
establishment was complicit in that so
Trump comes right back throws it right
back in calls Adam Schiff a traitor to
his country what happens was he cheered
on by the left and the same people who
cheered on the coals that he was a
traitor
no there was outrage from the mainstream
media outrage from the left outrage from
the anti Trump right they're not playing
by the same rules and President Trump
has this unique ability to draw the
hypocrisy out of his opponents because
he's a showman and he's putting on a
show and that's what Twitter is all
about Twitter is about performance TV is
about performance what he is showing us
as the hypocrisy of keeping the
hypocrisy in mind then we have to ask
the central question here because that's
what impeachment is all about what the
question of the civil war is all about
where is the corruption where's the
crime Rudy Giuliani on those shows gets
to the heart of the matter who was
corrupt here Joe Biden says it was the
old prosecutor in Ukraine who was
corrupt and that Joe Biden demanded that
that prosecutor be replaced by someone
else because he really cares about
Ukrainian domestic criminal justice or
something like that right I guess that
it this is where the Joe Biden defense
falls apart he says that old prosecutor
he was the corrupt one and the one that
I threatened to withhold American aid to
the tune of a billion dollars if they
didn't replace him the one that I picked
he was the good one and that's why we
got it withhold that aid and it was so
important he had to do it fast what does
Joe Biden care this is unprecedented
that a vice president would have the
ability to approve or disapprove of the
prosecutor in some foreign country
he just really cares about fighting
corruption in Kiev I don't I don't think
so
something tells me this there's
something else going on the Trump story
the story of conservatives are a little
more inclined to believe is the Joe
Biden forced Ukraine to ditch that old
prosecutor because that old prosecutor
was looking a little too closely into
Joe Biden and his son now it's not just
hearsay it's not like we just have to
rely on our own fantasies and our own
imaginings and third string gossip from
the CIA we have a sworn affidavit from
the old prosecutor saying exactly that
now look you could be lying all right
that's what investigations are for but
Rudy Giuliani goes on and provides even
more evidence that was done as a matter
of record in October of 2016 after the
guy got tanked he also dropped a case on
George Soros's company called an tak an
tag is the company where there's
documentary evidence that they were
producing false information about Trump
about Biden fusion GPS was there go back
and listen in Eleanor's testimony Nellie
Orr says that there was a lot of contact
between Democrats and the Ukraine well I
have all the contacts and John when the
rest of this comes out and we look at
China and the 1.5 billion that the true
that the Biden family took out of China
while that guy was negotiating for us
this will be a lot bigger than Spiro
Agnew they have fallen into a trap
they've fallen into a trap there it is
we will get to the even if you're
disinclined to believe that Rudy
Giuliani is telling the truth here that
Rudy Giuliani is the one you don't need
to just trust Rudy you don't need to
just trust the sworn affidavits we've
got Joe Biden contradicting himself
we've got Jay Carney Obama's former
press secretary alluding to some
corruption here we've got even Elizabeth
Warren showing that this looks crooked
we'll get to that we'll get to what this
means for 2020 Hillary Clinton's role in
all of this and whether we're really
headed for a civil war then of course
the negative effects of transgender
ideology already
already apparent six thousand kids have
been killed because of puberty blocking
drugs we'll get to that and we'll get to
Bill DeBlasio now that he's left of 2020
presidential race he's back to
destroying New York City as its mayor
now banning the word imposing fines if
you say the phrase illegal alien which
is a legal term that precisely describes
illegal concept we'll get to that all of
that more but you've got to go to Daily
wire come check out our new website
looks really great it's we fixed some of
the glitches over the weekend it looks
really sleek and really cool ten bucks a
month $100 for annual membership you get
me you get the end or Clavin show you
get the Ben Shapiro show you get the
Matt Walsh show you get all those things
and let me tell you something
subscriptions are more important now
than ever when we go out and we speak
the truth on this show and we say things
that maybe you're not politically
correct but they are politically crucial
to taking back our country from the left
there are whole organizations out there
that exist to watch our shows makes me
kind of funny I think it kind of makes
me laugh a little bit that those people
exist and their job is to watch our
shows but what they want to do is get us
cancelled that's why we need subscribers
that's why we need supporters because
the left fears outspoken conservatives
in this country they can't argue with us
they can't fight on the points so they
have to shut us down and shut us up
please head over to Daley wire.com we
appreciate all of your support and all
of the people who have already
subscribed it really means a lot it
helps us stay on the air head on over
there we got another Kingdom dropping
this week we got questions in the
mailbag which you can ask as a
subscriber all of that and so so much
more daily we're calm we'll be right
back
so on the actual point who was corrupt
is this impeachment inquiry against
Trump legitimate we know that there was
corruption on the part of the Biden's in
the Ukraine
we got the affidavits we got the
testimony we've got Joe Biden
contradicting himself and lying about it
in public Joe Biden was talking to Steve
do - I'm sorry - it was Peter Doocy the
other day on Fox News I actually
coincidentally was on Fox News while
this was happening so we saw it in real
time gave our instant reaction I
immediately knew what he was saying was
a lie and it has since been proven that
he was alive ducey asks Joe Biden have
you ever talked to your son about his
overseas business dealings Joe Biden
says no way no how mr. vice president
how many times have you ever spoken to
your son about his overseas business
dealings I've never spoken about his
overseas business that's a lie we knew
was a lie at the time now we can prove
it hunter Biden himself contradicted
this he told New York Magazine oh I'm
sorry The New Yorker back in July that
he did speak to his father about
Purisima and his father said quote I
hope you know what you're doing no
because he's a Biden he didn't know what
he was doing and he walked into that
trap and Joe Biden's lying about it
what's he like what's he trying to cover
up
we know it's crooked John Carl of ABC
News at least one journalist out there
asked the White House press secretary
Jay Carney about this in 2014 this is
Obama's spokesman when he asked about
the the Biden issue in the Ukraine the
White House spokesman didn't leap to Joe
Biden's defense didn't say there's
nothing going on he distanced himself he
stammered and he referred it to the vice
president's office here is hunter Biden
is not taking a position with the
largest oil and gas company
in Ukraine is there any concern about
least the appearance of a of a conflict
there see the vice prez for you to the
vice president's office I saw those
reports you hunter Biden and other
members of the Biden family are
obviously private citizens and where
they work is not does not reflect an
endorsement by the administration or by
the vice president or president but I
would refer you to the vice president's
office oh that's pretty bad Jay Carney
is usually pretty slick and even he
couldn't muster anything here he started
to almost defend hunter Biden what he
was about to start saying you could hear
it is hunter Biden is a private citizen
now the what the expected conclusion of
that is and therefore the the jobs that
are held by private citizens are of no
business of yours they have nothing to
do with politics and stop asking about
them he didn't say that when he ended up
doing was trying to protect the White
House actually so he said hunter Biden
is a private citizen and so whatever job
he has does not reflect an endorsement
by the president we had nothing to do
with it don't blame us even Elizabeth
Warren 2020 presidential candidate just
accidentally admitted that this is
corrupt the Biden dealings in Ukraine
before she realized that she had
admitted it was corrupt and then she
tried to walk it back she was asked the
question and a hypothetical is it okay
for the vice president's son to get
these slick deals out of foreign
governments and she initially says no of
course not then she realizes what it
means and she had to try to walk it back
too late I don't I don't know I mean I
have to go back and look at the details
I I have to go back and work oh she's a
real Indian giver on that answer isn't
she because she gives the obvious answer
she gives the correct answer which is
under a warrant administration so
warrants in President Warren mode here
she says would your vice president be
permitted to take bribes from foreign
governments she goes no of course not
absolutely not and then she realizes
what the question
and the question is do you think that
Joe Biden is a crook for allowing his
son to do this and she's not ready to
pounce on Biden obviously she wants to
beat Biden for the nomination but very
bad idea for her to do that now Biden's
falling apart she wants his support and
she doesn't want to be seen as having
caused his demise
or even worse siding with Trump to help
facilitate Biden's demise so she says no
absolutely not
and then the reporter good question says
why not why would you not allow your
vice president's child to get bribes
from a foreign government she goes I
don't know I mean you don't know you're
pretty quick on that answer you said no
obviously not
and the obvious reason is because that's
corrupt and crooked but then she says I
don't know and you have to I got to
think about it I bye see you then
there's a Liz Warren shaped hole in the
wall a lot of people including Rudy
Giuliani have uncovered a lot here so
can this stuff be trusted can what Rudy
Giuliani is saying on television be
trusted is it serious or not
the best argument that it's serious is
that Joe Biden wants to shut up Rudy Joe
Biden wrote letters his campaign wrote
letters to the TV news networks saying
quote we were writing today with grave
concern that you continued to book Rudy
Giuliani on your air to spread false
debunked conspiracy theories on behalf
of Donald Trump false he's got sworn
affidavits conspiracy theory what are
you talking about
he's got hard evidence on all these
shows they go on giving Rudy Giuliani
valuable time on your air to push these
lies in the first place it's a
disservice to your audience and a
disservice to journalism hmm so you're
telling me that totally uncorroborated
hearsay is enough to get the President
of the United States kicked out of
office but during an impeachment inquiry
sending the president's lawyer on
television with hard facts with sworn
affidavits with serious investigative
work that is a disservice to journalism
up is down black is white north is south
they go on while you often fact check
his statements in real time during your
discussions that is no longer enough
okay the Biden campaign is going to give
their lackeys in the media their
marching orders that's no longer enough
journalists do what we say by giving him
your airtime you're allowing him to
enter
increasingly unhinged unfounded and
desperate lies into the national
conversation it is always the case that
when they can't argue with your facts
with your evidence with your logic with
your arguments they try to shut you up
they try to get you kicked off
television they try to shut down your
show they try to get you canceled from
your Netflix special they try to get you
thrown out of office before the voters
have a chance to reelect you Democrats
are talking like they want civil war
they are
that's why Robert Jeffress brought it up
on TV that's why Trump tweeted about it
the RNC put an ad together with a lot of
these cases we're not just talking about
loony fringe lefties we're talking about
Maxine Waters Nancy Pelosi Hillary
Clinton all Fanning the flames in recent
years of violence and uprising
[Music]
I just don't even know why there aren't
uprisings all over the country maybe
there will be
you cannot be civil with a political
party that wants to destroy what you
stand for which it goes on and on I mean
that is a reckless reckless rhetoric
that is far more reckless than anything
Trump says you know you hear him go oh
the tweets the tweets are so terrible
not at all what Maxine Waters Hillary
Clinton are saying is far more reckless
far more damaging to public discourse in
the country Hillary Clinton just went on
television and and she lost the election
in 2016 and she is calling the current
President of the United States
illegitimate I believe he knows he's an
illegitimate president he knows he knows
that there were a bunch of different
reasons why the election turned out the
way it did and I take responsibility for
those parts of it that I should but Jane
it was like applying for a job and
getting 66 million letters of
recommendation and losing to a corrupt
human tornado and so I know that he
knows that this wasn't on the level I
don't know that we'll ever know
everything that happened but clearly we
know a lot and are learning more every
day and history will probably sort it
all out well we'll never know we'll
never know they it was the macedonians
who was James Comey it was I'm the
president I'm really the president she's
wandering around Chappaqua on a
straitjacket hillary hillary come back
come back
you forgot your medicine hillary say
what you will about Mitt Romney he
didn't call Barack Obama Nate legitimate
President John Kerry even didn't call
Bush and illegitimate president Bob Dole
didn't call Clinton a legitimate
President Bush one didn't call Clinton a
legitimate president but recently you've
seen this increasing Al Gore more or
less suggested that George W Bush was
illegitimate
Hillary is outright saying that's the
sort of talk that leads to civil war you
know there's a video going around of
auntie feh it's actually a video from
Canada but Canada's just America's hat
so you know it's pretty much the same
thing and Ann echoes scenes that we've
seen from Ann Tifa in the United States
especially in Portland but all over the
country
it's an Tifa physically threatening a
little old couple trying to cross the
street here they are
[Music]
this is the kind of stuff that leads to
civil war if you can do that to a little
old couple you've lost the narrative if
you think half the country is deplorable
and you're redeemable you've lost the
narrative if you are willing to question
legitimacy of the President the United
States or a Supreme Court justice like
Brett Kavanaugh or anybody else you have
lost the narrative you are seriously
diminishing faith in our institutions
especially if you were former senator
format Secretary of State former
Democratic nominee for president like
Hillary Clinton
unbelievably reckless I don't think
we're headed for civil war but if we are
it's because the left has whipped itself
up into a frenzy and if we are then I
guess the proximate cause of it will be
this stupid nonsense about hunter Biden
being a crook in Ukraine and Joe Biden
being a crook but there are great moral
questions here there are delet we can't
just write this off as some totally
frivolous farcical nonsense there are
serious moral questions a central
question would be abortion you've got
half the country they're digging in
their heels half the country says we
need to be able to kill babies as a
federal right you need to pay for it
half the country understands the reality
which is that it's bad to kill babies
okay that's a central question that is
certainly as big a question as slavery
was in 1860 a lot of the questions we're
talking about are about the relationship
of local communities to the federal
government so there was a little bit of
a of a truce at least on the abortion
question
because local communities could have
their own abortion laws different states
could have their own abortion laws Roe
vs. Wade
ended that and they've been the left has
been digging their heels in ever since
the other reason why I could see us
heading down a path to civil war is if
we've just become too shallow
this isn't about both sides this is
primarily a leftist issue the left does
not understand what the right is saying
you see this time and time again social
science shows this the the left actually
doesn't understand the arguments that
the
the right is making whereas the right
does understand many of the arguments
the left is making the left is much more
likely to unfriend people for having
different political views you know that
the first civil war was not caused by
shallowness whatever it was caused by
Lincoln Cent in the second inaugural we
all knew somehow the cause of it was
slavery and it was about Union and about
dis Union in this peculiar institution
but the second civil war could be caused
by a serious question any question that
causes war is by definition its serious
it could be caused by a serious question
it won't be caused by serious people it
will be caused by frivolous people
frivolously throwing away the greatest
country in the history of the world
farcical indeed electric Boogaloo is the
Civil War to on the surface you know
everything is going great below the
surface there are major cultural
questions to use just that one popular
issue we're talking about transgender
children and when you go out there
believe you made when you go out there
and you attack the leftist exploitation
of children vulnerable children what the
left does is twists that and pretends
that that's an attack on children
themselves well let's look at one
example of that we are now told if you
do not want to shoot little kids full of
hormones and block them from going
through puberty that you are hateful
you're bigoted you're transphobic you're
hurting these children you're
responsible for their suicide rates well
let's look at just one of those drugs
puberty blocking drug loop role ID
acetate which is good goes by Lupron is
a drug to block puberty and children by
definition if you're blocking puberty or
blocking puberty and children we have
just learned that this is resulting in
tens of thousands of serious adverse
reactions in recent years including six
thousand deaths six thousand dead
children because of a drug that blocks
puberty between 2012 and 2013 of this
year 2019 the FDA has documented over
forty thousand seven hundred sixty-four
adverse reactions to Lupron and more
than twenty five thousand five hundred
reactions in just the last five years
were considered serious including sixty
three hundred seventy deaths that's
according to the Christian Post
that is a shallow society that won't
even take up that question that won't
even look at look at the harm they're
doing is they are so misguided by
fantasy and ideology same thing look on
a completely different issue in New York
New York City is now banning the phrase
illegal alien they're not banning
illegal aliens which they should because
illegal aliens are illegal they're not
here and it and a self-governing people
has a right to determine its own
immigration policy
they're now banning the phrase illegal
alien if you use the phrase illegal
alien you could be fined up to a quarter
million dollars per offense this is
according to the civil holes city halls
Commission on Human Rights this is what
they write this is from the memo alien
used in many laws to refer to a non
citizen person is a term that may carry
negative connotations and dehumanize
immigrants marking them as other they
are other they're not American citizens
that's the purpose of language is to
distinguish between different concepts
and different ideas and different people
obviously if they were American citizens
who there wouldn't be the term illegal
alien because they wouldn't be other if
you use a different term to refer to
people it's other if you use the term
they want non citizen person you are
uttering them as well why because they
are other the use of certain language
including illegal alien and illegals
with the intent to demean humiliate or
offend a person or persons constitutes
discrimination so now the City Hall is
not only going to bridge free speech is
not only going to stop people from using
the correct term it's not offensive by
the way it is the most clinical term you
can use but it's it's not like you're
calling them some racial slur you're
calling them illegal aliens alien means
a foreign national and they're here
illegally they're not here illegally
there's no nicer term to use unless your
your goal is to deceive people which is
the point of politically correct
language now they're gonna read your
mind too and see if you really hate them
if you're really going to humiliate them
or to demean them that is a shallow and
frivolous and farcical society that
doesn't understand each other that won't
be allowed to communicate if we're not
even to use allowed to use words words
are the way that you can communicate in
civil society I just gave a speech about
this on Saturday at TP USA in Philly
speech is politics animals grunt only
human beings have the capacity for
speech to communicate with each other
about objective reality which is outside
of us if we are no longer permitted to
do that without being shut down without
being cancelled without being told that
precise language is against the law
there is no civil society there is civil
war a farcical civil war but a civil war
indeed that's our show let's hope it
never comes to that
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt Oh come back tomorrow we got a lot
more to talk about them
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner
executive producer Jeremy boy senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis clever and our
technical producer is Austen Stevens
assistant director pavel white house key
edited by Danny D'Amico audio is mixed
by Mike Cora Meena
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera and
our production assistant is Nick Sheehan
the Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey everyone its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know everyone
keeps saying that impeachment is a
serious business but nothing as serious
if it's not done seriously but Democrats
know that president Trump isn't going
anywhere so who is the target of their
so-called in Petri probe the target is
you I'll tell you why on the Andrew Klay
control
you